thinking of what to munch on one of our
favorites has a yummy recipe to share
hi drew i'm alice from hip footy mom and
today i'm going to show you how to make
the cutest halloween snack board i love
adding sweet and savory elements to my
halloween snack board so today i'm going
to show you how to make these cute
little mini mummy dogs it's really
important to
slice your dough into thin strips and
you're going to use this dough
to wrap around your little cocktail
sausage and you're kind of mimicking a
mummy guys here they are when they're
finished baking they are so cute you can
even put little dots of mustard for the
eyes they're so adorable and they're
delicious and no halloween snack board
is complete without cheese i love using
these halloween themed cookie cutters to
cut out super fun cheese shapes how cute
is that and now we're ready to build our
board if you have a centerpiece you want
to start with that and we're just going
to add some elements all around it guys
it's so easy to pick up halloween themed
cookies and candies at the grocery store
and you just fill in the board have some
fun with it
you can even have your kids help you
and it's always great to have candy of
all different sizes to help fill in the
gaps that you might have on your board
and here are the finished snack boards
we hope you try these for halloween drew
thank you so much for having me i had so
much fun
i'm gonna be thinking about that all day
[Music]